the world looks to china for signs of
future economic growth but its economy
has seen a sharp slowdown in the third
quarter china's economy grew 4.9 percent
compared to a year earlier slowing down
from the previous quarters 7.9 growth
rate it's another piece of bad news
after evergrand china's most indebted
property developer has kept global
markets on edge so what do china's woes
mean for the global economy the chinese
government is dealing with a combination
of headwinds policymakers pared back
stimulus measures put in place during
the pandemic last year this came around
the same time as a regulatory crackdown
on the technology private education and
real estate sectors this worried
investors
another worry concerns about evergrand
whose troubles have rattled markets and
raised questions about china's overall
economic and financial health home sales
and construction of new houses both fell
sharply in september there is also a
growing energy crisis driven by soaring
coal prices and efforts to lower energy
use as well as disruptions to supply
chains the question is now whether these
risks to the economy will crimp china's
growth in the final months of the year
beijing has made it clear that it wants
to take on long festering issues in the
economy such as reining in household and
corporate debt and pursuing ambitious
climate goals in 2020 china emerged as
the only major world economy to report
gdp growth amid the pandemic the
government is targeting annual gdp
growth of six percent or more this year
most economists are still confident that
china will be able to achieve this some
have begun to lower their forecasts